all right during our time reporting in
South Korea this week we had the
opportunity to walk the streets of Seoul
and speak with Americans living on the
Korean Peninsula and the trip was very
personal for me when I was 10 years old
I lived on one of the largest US
military bases in Asia US Army Garrison
Yongsan and it is right in the middle of
Seoul this week I visited my childhood
home I cannot believe it's exactly the
same more than 21,000 people are
stationed at the Yongsan US Army base
about a third of them are residents
including American servicemembers and
their families this space is right in
the center of Seoul almost
geographically and we look at the map
we're kind of like the only edge of the
river right in the center more than 30
years ago my family lived here for two
years my father a US Army commander
oversaw the 5th preventive medicine unit
can't believe we found it yes ma'am it's
is it it has not changed at all mmm it's
it's virtually the same garrison
commander Colonel Scott Peterson helped
us find my old house this whole area I
mean this military housing it hasn't
changed in like 32 years not much not
much the the residences are pretty much
the same again a lot of maintenance is
going on inside the homes but in terms
of layout location yeah I'm not a lot
changed my best friend lived there in
this duplex I lived here with my three
siblings and my parents I can remember
doing Easter egg hunts out back sure
it's different there used to be there
actually used to be a helicopter landing
pad in the back yeah that's no longer
there I can remember President Ronald
Reagan landing on that helipad in our
backyard in this picture from 1985 I'm
standing by the front door with my mom
and brother Here I am today in the same
spot that was my room right there yeah
that was my room even though the base is
about 25 miles away from the DMZ safety
was never a concern for us it was a
great place to grow up it really was a
great place because we could you were
safe even though you're in the middle of
a foreign country true in Seoul South
Korea
ride my bike and my parents weren't
worried about me all at 10 years old
they said go play no it's a great
community here very very close community
all the families are very closed the
kids all play together as you said it
couldn't be safer so we're very proud of
it
we also visited my school Seoul American
elementary so this would have been
probably my classroom very classroom
fourth grade classroom this is where you
went to school 30 years ago let's take
you inside
oh my thank you yeah so this one in your
classroom 30 years ago this would have
been my classroom yes my gosh it's it's
virtually the same this is the same
right the one thing that would be
changed is there's a TV yeah so it's an
interactive smart board that you
Medina's can you believe I was 10 years
old in this classroom today the
elementary school upholds its reputation
for delivering a top-notch education our
students are still performing at such a
high level yeah yeah they're able to go
to school anywhere they want to in the
country see you have you have a graduate
of this school who's now a journalist on
CBS it's a great thing yes it's a great
country it's a great installation yeah
it's a great place to live and work
that's for sure
the students do well though they still
are doing well and who knows we may have
the next CBS anchor here hi do one
different moral young son also just
happens to be where I started my career
in broadcasting yes there are a lot of
students giving on-camera English
lessons
voice voice nor a dream that she met
Christopher Columbus for the Korean
Educational Development Institute bouncy
repetitive to the hotel see you next
week bye bye everybody goodbye goodbye
no I wasn't so great yeah I was hoping
those tapes would never make the light
of day but now they have why would you
hope that I think that's adorable that
one had that it was a treasure it shows
how much she looked like your daughter's
don't you think Charlie they look or
they look like you Wow yeah it was neat
to go back and I think it's important to
remember you know so many it's not just
soldiers who are overseas their families
are sometimes with them and that's part
of the reason they're moving you know
out of
yongsan and moving it to camp humphreys
because i've got families they've got to
keep you safer for them yeah I think
it's interesting that ten years old you
knew you wanted to do this I just wanted
Barbie's Dreamhouse so here you knew at
ten years old that you wanted to do the
news I think that is amazing and here we
already know what you wanted to do at
ten no yeah that's it yeah I had no clue
what I wanted to attend you wanted to be
a doctor right early on yes yeah I
didn't change until I got to college no
no we're all here together
no her lucky us yeah all right great
trip welcome back nor oh thank you